hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to we happy few now apparently
we're in some sort of dystopian future
where everyone wants to be happy and no
one wants to acknowledge the sad sorrow
inside their souls but instead of that
we're gonna try to acclimate to natural
society and I have no idea what all this
is
psychotropic syringe why am I making
this in my basement I might ask myself
then I realize I'm a meth dealer okay so
either way I need to go out and greet
the day be happy take my joy take a
whole lot of joy and somehow learn to
fit in in society now this is an early
access game or its beta and it's
currently not out yet for a full public
release but it's more on the triple-a
side of things than it is on the indie
side of things I think still qualifies
as ending the game but there's a little
bizarre because we're in some strange
version of the UK yamimash would not be
proud of what's going on here Oh kind of
a fallout esque scavenge everything from
the environment type of deal
was there some type of nuclear holocaust
it happened around here and some reason
why everyone needs to be so happy all
the damn time okey-dokey then
well actually it kind of gives me a
Bioshock feel more than anything so I
need to greet the day take my joy
accompany other people do whatever the
hell they're doing and do something else
I have no idea what's going on to dare
and endure thanks good old stiff upper
hello oh yeah I never mind look at me l
weird those are the people with the
white faces are they yeah you guys don't
have a face hmm I don't know what
they're doing to me I don't know why
they're doing that to me
I didn't do anything to them okay drink
from pump okay fill container I didn't
know I had a container okay I did good I
guess or something
I still don't know what's going on here
or why but what my objective is
we are congratulations
I really don't want any part of the
that's weird okay alright I'm gonna go
on my way now I'm assuming that I'm not
to the part yet where everyone else is
supposed to be all normal and
understanding where they sorry okay the
music's nice the atmosphere is weird but
I'm still at a total loss of what I'm
supposed to be able to do do that looks
like something mm okay
oh okay so across the river is where all
society is and that's where I need to go
because I'm civilized not like these
brutes over here with their unclean and
shabby ways I shall venture fools okay
so I need to cross this bridge because I
fit in over here and definitely not over
there but I saw some people walking so
just let me group
let's go come on hide I don't need to
hide do I okay oh it's the happy police
how's it going we're all happy here
hahahaha downer Brio Downers oh that's
funny okay whoo I think ain't too good
boy watch go do it I'm not doing
anything what are you doing I'm just a
normal everyday human normal everyday
human don't my me go my me at all
it's good okay this is fun I'm glad I'm
here don't like me normal people search
for trash cans right hello everybody
everybody being happy today remember to
take your joy pills and your joy me
remember to slog down some joy
use me clear up so lovely day for it
Oh little bit lovely day for it play any
of humor are you when you tell me jokes
well I think I took on but you said a
bit and the first Oh comes from a dead
Prentice Gibson of Hobbiton town well ok
so red doors and ok well I seem to be
stuck I am stuck I am stuck I'm stuck I
found a bug found a bug found a bug
found a bug found a bug found a bug ok
there we go ok fine things aren't going
so well here you're a downer you need to
escape somewhere in the world is a
maintenance hatch find it and use it ok
ha ha shut up ok good jokes all aside
can I just take this house now is this
house now mine people are literally
outside this is actually really cool
there's a lot of depth to this world
around here thank you
oh I'm sorry ok never mind them lovely
day forward lovely day for lovely lovely
lovely lovely ah excuse me
oh crap I'm just gonna go now I'm gonna
go out and not get stuck cool never knew
a difference never knew anything lovely
day for it lovely day for it lovely
lovely if you'll only get fruit hello
lovely day for it
lovely lovely lovely lovely they'll be
dead lovely day for it lovely day
lovely day for it lovely day for it
lovely day probably there lovely lovely
day for it lovely day for it
lovely lovely lovely lovely day for it
lovely day for it I don't know what this
is all about tygo in here oh right I
don't know if I have enough joy I might
not have enough joy for this this might
be a horrible horrible horrible decision
should clear up soon I imagine
did have enough - oh no I didn't never
mind never mind I did not have enough -
excuse me sorry oh boy there's a lot of
joy in my brain go now just gonna go
just gonna go remember this game is in
alpha so it's not fully working here is
this high brow Society gives me lovely
therefore a lovely lovely lovely lovely
day for it lovely lovely in fact
actually extremely lovely lovely day for
lovely day fruit lovely day it's really
dark over here why is it so dark and
weird is this the poison in my brain
probably probably okay there we go let's
cut her now take joy okay I'm a downer
though whoo oh boy
well that's not
ah okay ah ah this is better this is
much better I need to drink come on
okay I drank did I drunk old
lovely day for a treat oh it's two it's
three in the morning oh that's why it's
dark okay three in the morning
I get it I got lovely day for it I'm not
a downer free are you a downer I'm not a
downer
ain't no downer I ain't down to nobody
not a thing I'm not tripping out what
are you doing okay right right so what
am i doing in here
is there like another uh ooh this might
be another yeah okay cool cool cool I'll
just uh don't mind me while I slip into
the sewer here okay thank you all right
so now the toys and those who won't
choose it are a threat to the rest of us
if you hear a good joke please don't
hesitate to drop a note not humor our at
our studio to Marlborough house in
central Wellington wells
yes I've really got to the end of our
time chewed it again next time for the
best in humor see you soon
the very best in humor I'm so glad
there's so much comedic value shooting
out of our eyeballs everywhere okay so I
don't have enough disposable lockpick
that's cool all right so that's
something at least
hmm
dang there's a lot more to this game
than I'm probably getting to because I'm
kind of blasting through everything like
quickly I don't intend to I just don't
have a clear objective because as a
downer I'm supposed to just either blend
in with society or escape and I'm not
entirely sure where I'm supposed to be
escaping to but I do need some water so
I gotta find water first it wouldn't be
a downer thing to drink straight out of
the fountain would it no not at all
also I noticed there are literally only
police around here lovely day
okay are you is right aly maybe maybe
it's only police patrolling because it
is actually late at night I'm an idiot
and I'm not actually realizing what I'm
the full ramifications what I'm doing
yes pretty I don't know where to go from
here sure do need some water though I
haven't seen the water pump since way in
the beginning I don't actually see any
buildings that I can go into around here
they all seem to be walled up both
towers here nowhere I'm your father
lovely day for it oh okay this makes
more sense now there's a bunch of people
out here but I still don't know what I'm
sure to be doing good
where the hell am i clear up soon I'm
you're gonna break an ankle no not you
don't know that let me just step into
the joy detector cuz it's worked so well
last time I just missed the button but
that's okay did you remember to shave
okay that's awesome take I can be gonna
be beaten
my face excuse me I'm almost dead oh
dear how are you doing I'm almost dead
excuse me about to sprint goodbye
everybody oh wow ended quickly doner a
debbie downer
welp there we go that was oh [ __ ] I died
okay so my first trying do we have if
you didn't work out so well I actually
didn't know what I was supposed to be
able to do umm there's obviously an
objective here beyond what I was just
doing which was random running around
and being an idiot which is what I
mostly do when I first play a game and I
don't get a lot of Direction not blaming
the game it actually is a lot of world
here and that's what's important about
this game because obviously this is just
beta there's a lot of world to be
explored there's a lot of depth to it
and there's a lot of detail and it's an
interesting universe where all of these
people are taking joy and being happy
and being happy by choice
so it's a really interesting I can't
wait to see until the full game gets
released which should be really cool but
maybe sometime next year I actually have
no idea when the release date actually
is but hopefully soon so thank you
everybody so much for watching and if I
did miss some stuff if there was some
stuff that I could see that I did not
get to because I was too much of an
idiot to see it let me know down in the
comments below and also let me know what
you think of this good thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video
so I need to find key